have you ever been stuck in deep snow no
we go hella skiing in Switzerland 10 000
feet 12 000 feet and they put beacons on
our chest like what's the beacon for he
goes it's better to locate the body I
said what I can find your body right
what do you mean find your body and he
goes it's for us it's not for you so we
start going all of a sudden I catch a
toe and I go phrase forward into the
snow and I disappear I take my arms to
push up oh and there's nothing there and
I'm like panicking going oh my God this
is what they mean yeah to find the body
sitting there for I'm not even joking 10
minutes upside down in snow and all of a
sudden I feel a hand grab my back pull
me up and he goes you should see your
sound guy my sound guy is upside down
now
and gear
everywhere and I was like get us the
off this mountain